now to the aftermath of the weeks of
protest and disruption in the nation's
capital the trucks are out of the
downtown core and some of the organizers
have been denied bail at least for now
david aiken reports
even as she was being arrested freedom
convoy organizer tamara leach called on
her supporters to hold the line we'll
see you soon tamara hold the line
that and other calls to action leach
made during her three weeks at the
center of the occupation of ottawa were
at the heart of a judge's decision
tuesday to keep leach behind bars and
deny her bail request until her trial
begins on the single charge of
counseling to commit the offensive
mischief it is a charge which carries
the potential of 10 years or more in
prison there is no doubt here the judge
told leach on conviction you are
certainly facing a potentially lengthy
term of imprisonment
convoy co-organizer pat king faces
similar charges he's been in jail since
he was arrested friday please step out
of the vehicle
prosecutors want to deny bail to king as
well a judge will decide on that on
friday
the proceedings in court occurred as
ottawa continued in recovery mode a
downtown corps still under police
restrictions but largely free of any
protesters and while mps are back in
their ridings senators started debating
the federal emergencies act with a focus
on the fact that authorities have frozen
more than 200 personal and commercial
bank accounts containing a combined 7
million dollars
they still need the tools
the economic measures that are designed
to limit financial support for these
illegal blockades they continue to play
an important role
and even though officials said the
process has started to unfreeze some
accounts opponents say the government
has failed to provide the evidence
needed to justify such extraordinary
powers you know senator gold
you'll excuse some of us if we just
simply don't believe the rhetoric that
we are
being given by the government if a
majority in the senate do not support
the government's invocation of the
emergencies act any extraordinary powers
being used by law enforcement will
immediately cease
david aiken global news ottawa
in ottawa the protesters the honking and
the trucks are gone but some police
checkpoints are still in place mike
armstrong spent the day speaking to
people who have waited for weeks to get
back to regular life
it didn't quite feel like a regular day
but michael hannis is very happy to be
back at work the brasserie metropolitan
was closed for weeks and hannes was
stuck at home with protesters outside
the best way i can describe it it was
like there was a lawn mower in my living
room 24 hours a day and then we got shot
down here at work so we lost uh three
weeks of pay four weeks of pay so it was
terrible
this was the scene outside the brass
reef during the protest management did
open for valentine's day but says it
wasn't worth it financially or
emotionally we were still dealing with
the excess incessant noise the fireworks
the honking the drinking people
urinating and defecating on the patio
a lot of businesses in ottawa's byward
market stayed open during the protest
but lost money public transportation was
shut down meaning people couldn't make
it and a lot of the ones who could were
nervous
erica gary didn't close but he lost
about 80 percent of his customers people
were scared to come down
so we have minimum we basically were
open
not to stay at home and go crazy
now life is still far from back to
normal the security zone around
parliament hill is smaller but it's
still a chunk of downtown that's
surrounded by an eight-foot fence and
police checkpoints it's just been insane
these men live in the security zone and
ventured out for the first time tuesday
still a little in shock it was it was
really brutal there was no police there
was no
neighbors were caring for each other
but we were forgotten
as if this area hadn't been through
enough there was a police operation on
this day the mall that's been closed for
three weeks was closed again for a
suspected armed shoplifter people who
had been out of work were out on the
streets
a lot of people in this city were
shaking their heads wondering what's
next the return to normalcy
isn't a straight line
mike armstrong global news ottawa